>From our table here we can see that the quantity x minus four times the quantity
x plus four is positive, or greater than zero, only when x is either less than
negative four or greater than positive four. So, these must be the intervals of
values of x that satisfy our original inequality. Since we now know that x minus
16 is greater than zero, it satisfied when either x is less than eight of four
or x is greater than four. Can you tell me about the solution set to sort of a
related inequality. X squared minus 16 is less than or equal to 0. Of course,
you can use our table down here for reference. And I'd like you to write the
answer using interval notation. Remember, that involves brackets that are either
square or round. Two numbers inside and then comas in between those numbers, and
of course, you can combine the brackets differently depending on what you need
for the interval.